bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 78 lactus ce mardi 18 mars
marqué par un mouvement de mobilisation
dans la fonction publique contre le
pacte de responsabilité proposé par le
gouvernement à l'appel de la CGT de FO
solidaire des salariés sont partis de
plusieurs point du département comme ici
à trrappe devant l'ancienne poste ils se
sont retrouvés pour prendre un départ
vers Paris ces syndicalistes dénoncent
notamment les sommes allouées au
patronat en France qui avoisinerait
selon la CGT 230 milliards d'euros il
dénonce également les conditions de
travail des salariés on va écouter
Jean-Michel l'union locale
CGT on l'appelle PCT de responsabilité
mais c'est un éè plan de de pour
l'emploi avec des aides supplémentaires
à un patronat qui qui qui utilise les
aides pour pour faire autre chose que
pour créer de l'emploi donc ça va pas
arranger y compris que ça va même
aggraver les choses parce qu'avec cet
argent là ils vont faire autre chose et
il y a aussi toutes les raisons qui nous
poussent aujourd'hui à agir dans les
entreprises et y compris descendre dans
la rue par rapport au aux simples
liberté dans l'entreprise le respect du
Code du travail des gens qui souffrent
dans l'entreprise qui soit ouvriers
employés cadre ingénieurs tous ces
gens-là ont une PR inadmissible dans les
entreprises et puis toujours dans le
domaine social ce lundi nous vous
parlions du mouvement de contestation
des équipes techniques de la société
d'bolt devant le siège social de
l'entreprise AG guuill en cours les
salariés ont été reçus ce lundi soir par
leur direction les dirigeants de
l'entreprise entreprise spécialisé dans
les automates bancaires leur auraiit
signalé qu'il n'y aura pas de
négociation tant que les salariés
continueront leur mouvement de grève
mouvement entamé depuis le 11 mars des
salariés qui ont choisi de maintenir
leur position et de son côté la
direction de dbolt France ne souhaite
faire aucun commentaire le Solar
Décathlon de Versailles a annoncé le
Parin de son édition 2014 il s'agit de
Michel desjoyot un marin depuis
longtemps concerné par le devenir de la
planète Olivier Maniscalco Jonathan Vman
vous allez me dire le parallèle entre
les bateaux à voile et et solar
Décathlon ben en fait sur un bateau à
voie la forceie en compétition on est
très économe en énergie
Michel desjoyau Parin du Solar Décathlon
Europe de Versailles c'est lors d'un
point presse le 17 mars au ministère de
l'Égalité des territoire et du logement
que l'annonce a été officialisée
compétition internationale
d'architecture environnementale le Solar
éira en juillet prochain le meilleur
projet étudiant de maison alimenté en
énergie solaire le navigateur
finisterérien double vainqueur du vent
des globes a tout de suite adhérer au
projet et apportera outre sa notoriété
une conscience écologique qui ne date
pas d' hier moi j'ai tout de suite
embrayé sur la
proposition à titre perso tout
simplement parce que moi je suis
passionné de technologie d'innovation de
compétition aussi mais je suis aussi
tout simplement citoyen mes deux
dernières maisons sont sont équipé de
panneaux solaires thermiques même en
Bretagne il assez de soleil pour
chauffer de
l'eau et sur la prochaine dont j'ai
déposé le permis de construire récemment
j'ai bien l'intention de mettre du
solaire thermique du solaire
photovoltaïque euh de de l'éolien de la
récupération euh d'autres pluies pour la
première fois organisée en France la
compétition accueillera du 16 juin au 19
juillet les projets de 20 nationalités
différentes des projets qui seront
exposés au grand public durant 18 jours
près du château de versaill le Solar va
ainsi permettre un coup de projecteur
sur la maison écologique du futur c'est
le moyen de de montrer qu'on peut
construire différemment qu'on peut
améliorer des bâtiments existants et
qu'on peut faire beaucoup d'économie
d'énergie et utiliser les énergies
renouvlable dans le bâtiment et puis de
montrer aussi toutes les inventions
toutes les innovations qui sont en cours
dans ce secteur c'est c'est une bonne
manière de montrer effectivement qu'on
est plus seulement dans l'innovation
l'innovation est en train de de de
découler dans dans dans nos réalisations
concrètes et c'est nécessaire parce que
la transition énergétique c'est vraiment
le challenge du 21e siècle de notre
continent et donc de notre pays lors de
ce solar Décathlon Europe de projets
français seront présentés en 2012 lors
de la dernière édition c'est un
prototype grenoblois qu' l'avait
emporté ce dimanche France Miniature à
hencour a accueilli Jean-Luc Pasquier
les pores pararole d'Astrium c'est le
leader européen de l'industrie spatiale
à l'occasion d'une animation autour de
la maquette d'Arian 5 Aurélia debici
Jonathan
villman près de 450 kg de résine et 1500
heures de travail auront été nécessaires
à la fabrication de la fusée arien 5
inaugurée en 2011 à France Miniature car
oui il s'agit bien d'une reproduction 12
cette maquette de plus de 2 M60 était à
l'honneur ce dimanche pour une animation
découverte de l'espace au programme un
quiz pour évaluer ses connaissances et
la rencontre avec un expert spécialement
accueilli par le parc touristique pour
l'événement tout le monde est fasciné
par l'espace Jean-Luc Pasquier est là
aujourd'hui pour pour répondre à toutes
ces questions Arian 5 comment comment
elle a été créée et pourquoi et il
apporte un peu plus de précision sur
l'espace maintenant je voulais parler un
peu de la Station spatiale
internationale est-ce que vous
connaissez oui dans gravity et ben on en
parle dans gravity absolument c'est une
bonne façon de connaître l'espace même
si tout n'est pas parfait dans gravity
il y a ici une magnifique maquette de
Arian 5 c'est c'est toujours une fusée
qui est importante pour pour l'Europe et
pour notre société puisque on est on en
est le fabricant elle est bien plus
petite que laavra Arian mais elle est
très
représentative dans dans dans tous ces
aspects hein on explique
diffutilisation des satellites le fait
que il y en a qui sont en orbite très
très basse et qui servent par exemple à
faire des photos dans d'autres en orbite
un peu moyenne par exemple qui servent à
la navigation et puis d'autres sur la
fameus orbites géostationnaire qui sont
juste au-dessus de l'équateur et qui
servent essentiellement pour les
télécommunications mission accomplie
après décryptage tout semble plus clair
pour ces jeunes visiteurs j'ai découvert
où se lancer les fusées comment était
fabriqué les fusé comment ça
décollait où ça été lancé pardon voilà
les animations sont sans supplément au
prix d'entrée du parc prochaine date à
retenir le weekend de pâqu ou le
chocolat sera bien entendu à la
fête le festival d'humour et de café
théâtre de rock en cour 18e du nom va
s'ouvrir du 19 au 21 mars au command
d'Éric bouverron son directeur
artistique bonsoir éic bonsoir alors ce
festival j'ai envie de dire c'est une
sorte de concours d'ailleurs c'est un
concours puisquil y a des candidat il y
a un jury il y a un public qui peut
voter ça pass et des invités et des
invités ça se passe comment sur ces TR
jours il faut imaginer C tris soir de
spectacle de festivités euh avec ces
artistes qui jouent pour gagner un peu
le piolet d'or qui est le le trophée il
joue aussi pour gagner un peu de sous
parce que c'est un des rares festival où
il y a des sponsors qui met de l'argent
pour les gagnant mais c'est surtout un
festival pour encourager les les talents
que ce soit jeunes ou des gens confirmés
c'est un type de du festival d'humour
comme on peut dire le festival de cinéma
à Cannes donc on essaie de vraiment
encourager ça et découvrir un peu des
des nouveaux talents et des talents
qu'on connaît pas du tout alors
justement ces artistes comment vous
faites le choix est-ce que vous d'abord
vous vous les voyez tous vous voyez tous
les spectacles les artistes il y a une
équipe il y a l'association La AFR qui
est de de reconcours euh mon rôle c'est
de de dénicher trouver ou faire
connaissance des artistes déjà un
présélection et les inviter sur des
soirées qui qui déroule dans les
théâtres théâtre de Bougival par exemple
et le le Royal Factory à Versailles et
sur différentes soirées d'audition on
organise des soirées dans des bonnes
conditions devant des publics et il
montrre un peu 10 minutes de leur
univers et après on a visionné une 30
quarantaine d'artistes on choisit les
neuf univers mais qu' y avait déjà
présélection sur toute l'année quand
même déjà une prélection oui parce que
ça se travaille et des fois même 3 ans
en avant par exemple Nadia rose qui qui
participe cette année ça fait 3 ans de
suite quand on la suit pour voir
jusqu'au moment elle est assez mû pour
être face à un plateau comme comme celle
de Ronc mais qu'est-ce qui vous touche
vous particulièrement qu'est-ce qui vous
fait rire parce que c'est quand même un
festival d'humour donc je présume que
quand vous allez vous allez faire la
présélection il faut que ces artistes
vous fassent rire qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui fait rire bouveron c'est
l'émotion c'est le texte c'est la
gestuelle il n a pas je pense que qu'il
n'y a pas de de de règle ce qui fait ri
parce que le r peut apparaître à
n'importe quel moment c'est la surprise
l'inattend
il n'y a pas on peut pas dire c'est tel
artiste qui me fait rire tel non plus
l'humour est on a tous notre côté
d'humour je pe j'ose dire tout ce que je
sais c'est que le rire est nécessaire le
rire j'adore rire j'adore faire les
autres rire
donc non c'est bien que il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas une méthode ou un loi sur
qu'est-ce qui fait qui fait rire mais je
sais surtout c'est que le rire vraiment
naisse à son meilleur endroit quand il a
son opposé la tragédie comme Charlot
faisait il savait très bien que pour
faire vraiment rire les gens en
profondeur il fallait les toucher là où
ça fait mal s les fait par exemple le
dictateur qui parlait de de la deuxème
Guerre mondiale il a pu faire rire les
gens beaucoup plus là-dessus parce que
le drame était présent également ou on
pense aussi à la vie belle ah par
exemple c'est vraiment un thème très
lourd
avec il faut les contrastes alors avant
on continue de parler de de spestival je
vous propose de regarder des extraits de
certains artistes qui sont invités on
aura pas les neuf artistes mais on va en
voir quatre en tout cas on va écouter
Victori Nadia rose dont vous avez vous
avez parlé je trouve très énergique les
glandeurs nature et Daniel Camu regarde
un extrait ces artistes il me demande de
faire étoile
je je je fais quoi là je hein moi je dis
tu te mets comme
ça oh je suis con on a perdu un mod
acédiques les enfants venez
voir
vous voyez le monsieur là-bas accroché à
son fil là ouais oui oui et ben c'est un
monsieur qui resté bloqué une autre
époque PIP PIP ouais PIP PIP ouais
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le Big Deal B
qu'est-ce qu'il a gag ce soir un
magnifique voyage pour de à New York ou
alors le rideau le rideau le rideau le
rideau le rideau rideau rideau
d'O bien plus simple que ton
ordinateur je te présente
l'aspirateur une seule fonction
vois-tu aspirer tes poils
de je peux pas savoir comme j'ai la
trouille de rencontrer une femme en ce
moment ah ben si c'est que ça
t'inquiètees pas tu es à l'abri
toi je derrière tu veux je pas de
problème allô bonjour non pas bonjour
merde j'ai
pas élégant comme c'estad comme
Scaramouche je très bienon à la fin de
l'envoie je me
touche voilà ça c'est les glandeurs
nature à la fin est-ce que l'humour est
quelque chose de masculin parce que dans
la sélection il y a qu'une femme qui est
toute seule enceinte c'est narose qu'on
a vu en extrait c'est le hasard que pour
cette cette sélection c'est jolie
question parce que comme dans la vie il
y a des choses féminins et masculin moi
je crois que l'humour est beaucoup plus
proche du côté masculin euh il n'a pas
la fin
de le côté féminin je pense que s'il y a
la beauté et l'humour pour moi on a le
féminin et le masculin je sais pas
pourquoi c'est quelque chose une femme
qui fait rire je pense que elle est très
forte quand elle peut nous faire rire
avec sa côté féminin tandis que comme
l'humour est tellement du
ventre c'est je pense c'est beaucoup
plus c'est oui c'est un élément masculin
oui je pense je suis perdu
dedans compliqué de trouver des artistes
humoristes féminines et c'est pour ça
que pour cette sélection par exemple sur
les neuf candidats il y a qu'une femme
vraiment toute seule sur scène c'est
juste l' hasard des choses des fois il y
a plus des femmes les désinguer les
groupes musical elles sont les deux ce
sont les deux femmes qui chantent et qui
mènent le bateau là par exemple les deux
hommes qui font que que la musique dans
dans par derrière mais le je pense c'est
Lazar aussi que cette année il y avait
plus d'hommes qui avaient plus une force
dans le dans le comic d'accord qu'est-ce
que ça apporte porte justement à ces
artistes ce festival alors vous avez dit
un petit peu d'argent mais ENF je pense
que c'est pas il y a le plolet d'or ça
c'est très très important de ça ça
permet quoi de rencontrer un public
évidemment de rencontrer des des
programmateurs tout à fait dans le le
but de ce festival c'est de ouvrir les
portes pour ces artistes leur permettre
de de retravailler derrière de regagner
leur vie de de donner un peu de
notoriété un peu plus n'oublions pas que
c'est un festival qui a fait connaître
des gens comme Julie Ferrier Éric
Antoine parmi d'autres donc c'est a tout
début ah je pense non s elle était dans
le jury P c'est bien c'est bien il faut
passer par partout ce qui intéresse qui
n'est pas le cas d'aujourd'hui mais les
humoristes comm moi j'ai démarré pas mal
dans le dans les théâtres à Paris et en
France on travaille dans des petites
salles il fallu monter les l'échelle
doucement pour se faire connaître
aujourd'hui la télé peut propulser
quelqu'un tout tout de suite tandis que
le métier ça se ça se travail ça ce
travail pour moi et en tout cas pour
revenir à cette question là parce que je
passe à l're côté c'est que le un
festival comme REC concours permet les
artistes de donner le meilleur
d'eux-même pour développer leur travail
et que ils ouvrent leur porortes puis
qu' qu'il puissent gagner leur vie avec
ça et surtout dans le juris il y a des
programmateurs qui peuvent les
programmer derrière j'essaie d'imaginer
que si j' artiste tu voudrais ça comme
jury devant moi donc un jury avec un
parrain du festival Philippe dvis qui
est administrateur de l'Académie Alfonse
Saly il y a aussi des artistes invités
avec des styles différents jonglage
humoriste visuel et et Ventrilo et puis
un dernier mot pour dire que les
meilleurs se retrouveront le 26 avril
sur la scène du théâtre mont-ancier vers
mont-ancier on essaie de faire un peu le
Best Off de ce festival de reconcours
comme ça comme si c'était un autre
spectacle disons le le le le dernier feu
d'artifice de de l'événement voilà donc
si vous voulez assistez au festival de
roncours c'est du 19 au 21 mars à
roncours sur la scène du Théâtre André
Maler le best of du festival ce sera le
26 avril sur la scène du théâtre
mont-ancier à Versailles et puis si vous
voulez voir Éric gouverron parce que
vous êtes aussi hauteur vous vous venez
d'adapter pour la scène les chevaliers
de Joseph qui celle que vous mettrez en
scène au Festival d'Avignon ce sera en
juillet 2000 en juillet en juillet de de
cette année si vous vouz vous promener
du côté d'Avignon pour applaudir Éric
bouverron merci beaucoup d'être venu sur
le plateau du 78 lactu merci cette
édition est terminée merci de votre
attention demain vous retrouvez wilfri
Richy tout de suite municipal 2014 le
magazine dédié au scrutin local dont le
premier tour se déroule le 23 mars bonne
soirée à
vous